quoi de mieux que la mairie écoles pour
montrer le symbole de la citoyenneté de
nos territoires ruraux dans les années
1880 les lois ferry rendre
l'enseignement primaire gratuit et
obligatoire et impose de disposer d'une
école publique et laïque par commune
s'ensuit l'obligation de construire en
plus une mairie les communes rurales du
parc naturel de chevreuse font ainsi
d'une pierre deux coups et baptiste un
édifice municipal à la fois école et
mairie
un inventaire de ces mairies écoles a
été effectuée par la mission patrimoine
du parc
la ville de réseaux a été l'une des
dernières à disposer de ce bâtiment à
double vocation qui a été construit en
1910 il faut savoir que nous avions un
vieux vieux bâtiment qui la têt du xviie
siècle xviiie siècle et qui servait de
mairie et ce bâtiment là a perduré
jusque dans un et 1903 ou là le préfet
voyant les conditions déplorables de la
vie de nos écoliers a mis en demeure la
commune de construire un nouveau
bâtiment
seul problème c'est que la communauté
extrêmement pauvre et il a fallu près de
40 ans pour pouvoir mettre en oeuvre
c'est la condition de cette mairie pour
les mettre en valeur les mairies écoles
sont construites en coeur de village
puis pour certaines communes la
construction d'une nouvelle école a
donné une nouvelle fonction à leur
mairie pour d'autres il a fallu agrandir
le bâtiment initial pour faire face à la
croissance de la population
physiquement nous avons exactement le
même bâtiment
au niveau des classes eh bien on a été
amené à créer une deuxième place voire
une 3e place
on a créé une unité de bâtiments et
illimité architecturale entre ces trois
classes autre petite histoire veut que
tout le monde connaît c'est que les
directeurs d'école habitait dans la
mairie en réalité est que ce qui
resterait pour les locaux communaux
étaient réduits à une voire deux pièces
temps qu'il a fallu négocier dans les
années 90 avec le directeur de l'école
pour qu'ils puissent enfin nous libérer
la mairie et rendent cet espace au
public cet inventaire des mairies écoles
en vallée de chevreuse est disponible
sur le site internet du parc